les présidentielles de 2022 sont bel et
bien lancé eric zemmour ou jean luc
mélenchon de france que tout oppose les
français ne veulent plus finances
mais deux candidats qui pourrait bien
faire pencher la balance dans les
sondages crédités 11% chacun il partage
les idées de nombreux français j'exprime
des idées qui sont suivis à peu près si
j'en crois tous les sondages par 70% des
français mais qu'en est il de les
confronter
ce soir jean luc mélenchon prend la
parole dans tpm
place et l'autre avec no mercy raquel
garrido que j'avais mal le sait
la division j'écris que parti réclamait
oui mais
qui s'en va et en fait il s'en va pas
ça me fait plaisir de voir tous les deux
à côté avec votre témoin de mariage
en chalencon est avec nous et c'est vrai
que ce débat entre eric zemmour et jean
luc mélenchon a fait couler beaucoup
d'encre parce que au départ jean luc
mélenchon avait dit je ne débattrai pas
avec eric chine déjà je vais me faire
l'avocat du diable et l'avocat de
jean-luc mélenchon moi aussi j'avais dit
je ne recevrai jamais eric zemmour et je
vous dis pourquoi ya plein de gens qui
militent aussi tu avais dit que je
recevrai jamais réglé mots je pense
qu'avant quand j'ai dit ça c'était à 3,4
on n'était pas armé pour le recevoir
j'avais pas non plus les gens autour de
moi pour recevoir exe moore aujourd'hui
je considère qu'on est plus armé
d'ailleurs à quel vous serez avec moi
dans l'émission bien entendu si on le
reçoit un jour mais c'est vrai que voilà
donc on peut changer d'avis voilà eric
zemmour je préfère aujourd'hui avoir des
débatteurs en face de lui essayez dû
proposer d une contradiction plutôt que
de laisser dérouler tout seul
ccc idéologie et c'est vrai que je peux
comprendre jean luc mélenchon va voir sa
réponse dans un instant mais je le dis
aussi à beaucoup de gens qui me disent
oui ces résultats vous êtes maintenant
que les deux s'échangent et voilà
aujourd'hui je pense que on peut le
recevoir plus qu'on aurait pu le faire
avant et qu'aujourd'hui vaut mieux le
laisser débattre avec des gens fassent
que le lait s'est déroulé tout seul
raquel et alexis pourquoi il a changé
d'avis jean-luc non mais franchement il
a pensé comme vous ne versez pas la même
chose quelqu'un qui est chroniqueur tous
les soirs dans une émission très
délimité où ils déroulent sur des
thématiques obsessionnel on sait très
bien qu'à trop de musulmans au fond il
faut les chasser le problème du pays ce
serait pas la pauvreté se serait pas la
crise écologique se serait pas la crise
démocratique c'est qu'à des gens qui
s'appellent mohamed et ses terres bon
c'est obsessionnel c'est malsain le
problème c'est que là il est en train
d'être candidat à la présidence de la
république il a une stratégie jusqu'au
bout il va tarder pour officiellement
l'annoncé mais il va saturer l'espace
médiatique d'aaron poèmes s'interroger
il a vite votre profession de comment ça
se fait que depuis trois semaines c'est
le sujet obsédant mais il est candidat
pour venir jusqu'à vous il ya des
affiches sur les murs de paris et aussi
en province z comme zorro la tête à
zemmour il est potentiellement candidat
donc à partir de là parce qu'ils
changent de statut pas ce qui pèse sur
le débat politique particulièrement à
droite je sais pas si vous avez vu les
candidats de la droite nishi cours on
peut après l'été mais alors vraiment on
a vu aujourd'hui un sondage 1 qui lui
oui le son sur cent il à égalité avec
dans les plans travailleurs se lancer
dans le dernier sondage qui est sorti
xavier bertrand est à 14
donc je vais bouleversent le paysage
politique est ce que c'est vrai ou pas
j'en sais rien mais quoi qu'il en soit
dans l'image et l'entrée en campagne et
mélenchon lui comme nous en tant que
porte parole des candidats
il a le sentiment nous avons le
sentiment que comme vous l'avez dit il
n'y a pas de réponse politique vraiment
qui sera portée et c'est peut-être si on
aura le temps d'en parler c'est que ces
mots il développe une vision de la
france et nous on n'en développe une
autre
en gros je vai le résumé j'espère que ce
qui m'est vous de comprendre on sait
soit la france est une nation civique
avec des citoyens égaux en droit une
nation civique soit c'est une nation
ethnique l'idée des émaux sexy nation
ethnique en gros c'est un vieux pays un
essentiellement catholique qui existe
depuis des siècles même bien avant la
république en gros la république c'est
un petit moment et d'ailleurs ils
n'aiment pas en soi les déclarations des
droits de l'homme moi il m'a j'ai déjà
discuté avec lui me dit tout ça c'est du
baratin et il amène à la conclusion
finalement ceux qui sont musulmans et il
a même dit il faut demander aux
musulmans dit-il de choisir entre
l'islam et la france tracts bon à calais
à lire absolument un petit truc est
sorti et là dont tout le monde parle
également avant qu'on voit la première
partie de la vidéo tour luc mélenchon
pourquoi ils débarquent éric démon on a
vu qu'il avait été à l'anniversaire
d'eric zemmour en 2008 à ses 50 ans et
c'est vrai que ton dans la parler
aujourd'hui et tout mon avis pourquoi il
n'a pas il ne l'a pas dit qu'il est
arrêté à l'anniversaire des 50 ans et
qu'en bas
juste pendant laquelle mais par moments
il l'a dit c'est pas un scoop il y avait
plein de gens qui étaient là jean
christophe cambadélis qui a été premier
secrétaire du parti mais c'est sûr que
c'est franchement non mais le problème
c'est que moi j'ai connu eric zemmour à
une époque je sais pas si ça parle
encore aux gens mais il était très
proche de philippe seguin était une
figure la droiture physicien
obsessionnelle sur ces trucs et c'était
à droite gaulliste un peu anti europe
etc c'était pas le même bonhomme il ya
13 ans n'était pas le même il était
chroniqueur chez ruquier bon c'était la
droite une journaliste au figaro très
bien et mélenchon il discute avec les
gens de droite mais depuis quelques
années il est partant d'angrie
aujourd'hui jean-luc mélenchon n'y avait
pas l'anniversaire d'eric zemmour ah bah
oui non mais ils se parlent plus cherry
bomb parler donc alors vous allez voir
la première partie de la réponse de
jean-luc mélenchon qui nous a fait que
pour nous donc merci jean luc en
exclusivité pour touche pas à mon poste
et il a accepté nous dire pourquoi il
avait finalement accepté de débattre
avec eric zemmour et vous allez voir
après dans une deuxième partie il va
assez fort sur l'eczéma mais regardez
déjà pourquoi il a accepté de débattre
finale
[Musique]
défilant débat
sur la question qu'ils ont cherché
des mois
je vais non le dans l'ambré jeudi soir
alors ça c'est la première partie de la
vidéo vous allez voir après il a des
mots assez durs sur jean luc mélenchon
vous êtes corneille pas et vous êtes ami
d'eric zemmour ou plutôt partisan d'eric
zemmour d'abord je suis ami moi je
connais depuis pas vous voteriez pour
lui s'il se présentait je dis pas non
batman under the sea et c'est étonnant
d'ailleurs le nombre de jeunes de genre
de différence couche couches
socioprofessionnelles qui veulent voter
pour lui moi je connais rit toujours par
napoléon parce que c'est un passionné
d'histoire eric staal un compteur c'est
un historien et eric c'est quelqu'un qui
est passionné et donc je comprends qu'il
ait envie de développer son livre ses
sujets qu'il avait écrit dans son livre
comment vous il va se présenter je peux
que j'en sais rien mais je pense que
s'il ne se présente pas au moins il aura
fait la démarche de dire ce qu'il pense
et de réveiller les partis le parti du
président les républicains il ya un
moment peu plus abaisser le niveau de la
société française comme aujourd'hui
s'est abaissée enfin il ya quand même un
hulk en selle culture qui est
catastrophique d'ailleurs pourquoi sa
chaîne de télévision marche si fort avec
christine kelly pas parce que les gens
sont passionnés et en province moi je
vois des gens de et c'est pas de droite
de gauche allégeant les gens l'écoutent
parce que il est passionnant alors c'est
quelqu'un de passionnant le clan des
mots on l'a eu au téléphone il évoque un
choc de titans il ne s'arrête à ce choc
des titans selon les proches d'eric
zemmour ce débat permet de dire qu'à
droite il n'ya que zemmour et à gauche
que mélenchon se débat pour but de
renforcer les deux camps voilà
d'éliminer en fait anne hidalgo
d'éliminer tous les gens à gauche et
d'éliminer aussi à droite voilà que
xavier bertrand valérie pécresse et
c'est de lire à gauche aya macron et à
gauche à gauche mélenchon et à droite et
moi c'est ce qu'ils espèrent en fait
créé tous les deux est-ce que c'est
aussi la stratégie de jean luc mélenchon
laquelle je pense que la stratégie de
jean luc mélenchon c'est surtout de
parler au plus grand nombre une élection
présidentielle contrairement aux
élections intermédiaires c'est un moment
de délibération avec la nation tout
entière et c'est sûr que si on fait
débattre deux personnes qui sont
extrêmement médiatisé qui sont des poids
lourds de l'audimat à la fin ça provoque
beaucoup d'audimat donc des gens qui
sont dans la maison qui sont devant la
télé est pour moi un téléspectateur
c'est un citoyen c'est quelqu'un qui
essaye de se forger une opinion
politique ou affirmé déjà d'esprit
supposer qu'il a ou peut-être les
nuances et pour en définitive un jour
voté et ainsi être le souverain voilà
c'est pour ça que l'info ce genre de
grands moments et des services publics
qui le fqih le faire parce que
l'émission politique là du service
public depuis un tas donne alors je sais
comment c'est bien de choisir quelque
chose jean luc mélenchon ne voulait pas
aller sur france 2 une bonne cote france
2 il service public et c'est vrai qu'il
ne souhaite pas mais disons que c'est
vrai que les bichonne avec l'émission et
mais durement xi d'accord avec vous on
ne répond à son lit jamais caché ici et
réveillant le russe aurait on dit 500
laitiers ccpc tirerait sais pas c'est
pas fou
jean luc mélenchon n'a pas voulu venir
ici je lis parce que et je vais vous
dire pourquoi et je le comprends aussi
là dessus il sait le groupe canal+ donc
forcément l'aérés xénon va jouer à
domicile je peux le comprendre aussi
franchement même si nous on a une
liberté d'expression et vous le savez
raquel wii et qui travaillent avec moi
vraiment on fait on a je n'ai jamais ni
de dire telle ou telle chose on aura
peut-être la revanche sur valence temps
passé exactement mais c'est vrai que ici
on a une liberté d'expression totale et
eric zemmour n'aurait pas jouer à
domicile parce que on le bouscule
souvent et on sait qu'on va le recevoir
on va on va bousculer donc mais je peux
comprendre l'union qui dit pour le match
aller en tout cas il va pas jouer à
domicile donc ils ont choisi le groupe
bfm voilà next radio et bfm tv donc je
peux le comprendre mais la stratégie a
beaucoup d'eau qui je te jean luc
mélenchon il veut profiter aussi du
phénomène zemmour qui est maintenant on
le voit dans les sondages sais pas si
ces sondages sont on se méfiera autour
des sondages mais il est au coude à
coude avec eric zemmour là dans les
sondages à 11% et qu'ils et je veux
profiter du phénomène emo en herbe ont
justement d'être un petit peu de moi
dans la machine mais ces récits et
repartir il est ce que c'est vraiment
parti est ce que ceux qui nous regardent
pense sincèrement que c'est mélenchon et
ce débat qui fait de la pub à zemmour
comme je les ai entendus est ce que ceux
qui nous regardent pense sincèrement que
jean luc mélenchon a besoin de ce débat
pour se faire connaître aucun risque en
fumée dans les écoles je discute avec
moins vite seront comme député
évidemment nos enfants ils connaissent
trois personnages politiques jusqu'à
présent emmanuel macron madame le pen
jean-luc mélenchon en bien ou en mal
c'est pas le sujet donc jean luc
mélenchon ne souffre pas de notoriété
gens les peuls ont chanté 7 millions de
voix dix neuf et demi pour cent oui mais
pas contre non mais revenons il est
crédité de 11% à ben c'est pas mal
pardon je vais vous avez l'air perdu il
a perdu menant attendez moi j'ai créé ce
moment là ne sont pas une présidentielle
en septembre 2016 on était au même
niveau au seuil en février 2017 quand
monsieur hamon gagne la primaire on
tombe à 8 % d'accord donc ça les
sondages actuellement aux arbitres au
nom met d'accord avec toi que si faire
très bon débat contre zemmour là il ya
le délire lusala est extrêmement
bénéfique ce que je veux dire c'est que
pendant le débat au sérieux c'est
d'abord un débat d'idées eric zemmour et
le champion d'une idée qui existent dans
le pays depuis au moins deux siècles ce
que je vais appeler vie des contre
révolutionnaires en gros les citoyens ne
sont pas égaux les citoyens sont liées à
une terre à un sol à une tradition on
peut pas en sortir et si tu n'es pas de
cette tradition tune pas être français
et jean luc mélenchon et le champion
d'une autre idée est beau moi quelle que
soit la couleur de ta peau quelles que
soient ses convictions spirituelles que
tu crois en dieu ou pas quel que soit
ton nom mais la composition
ça fait très mal battu cette acquisition
s'est fait très très mal depuis cette
perquisition les élections moins bien
marché il a besoin il a besoin de
restaurer son image c'est ça le fond du
débat là et c'est ça qui m'a enfin de
zemmour non mais ça devrait tirer dès
qu'on sait c'est mathieu non c'est pas
un risque d'assister qu'il aima
mélenchon qui menait alors 7 à crème à
obernai ce que dit jean luc mélenchon
eric zemmour garde hop il est dur la
tension est de faire vivre aux yeux de
tous ils ne savent pas quelle gifle et
sa vision de la hanche quel est
justement ce serait si on le suivait et
qu'elle dérange et je vais courir
le jeune a le poison de la vie julie
dray vent et la guinée musulmans et
juifs o'shea
oui mais moi je trouve que j'en ai plein
champ il fait un énorme cadeau pour on a
d'un côté un candidat solide à la
présidentielle qui a fait 19 % en 2017
et de l'autre un polémiste qui tente de
devenir candidat est là en acceptant le
débat avec lui il y aura une sélection
de candidats cible alors et deux sirènes
et regagneront moi je vais regarder le
débat franchement je vais je mens
délecter mais du point de vue de jean
luc mélenchon je pense pas que c'était
une bonne idée d'accepter bon guillaume
guillaume ce que vous dites je vous
assure pendant on en a discuté avec jean
luc mélenchon est ce que vous pensez à
moi ou un mot tous les dons vie d'un
même pays que depuis trois semaines ce
qui fait de la pub à monsieur zemmour ce
qui met la lumière sur ces mots c'est
jean luc long chemin non c'est plutôt le
fait d'y arriver nous mêmes crédits mais
là il avait besoin d'une crédibilité oui
les hanter
on a discuté manuel valls a discuté
jean-christophe des 19 ministres et par
contre pas candidat n'est ni la première
fois qu'il est neuf rencontres nice caen
malgré la distance est battu avec eric
zemmour il ya quelques mois nord et
ministre donc quand vous êtes ministre
mais peut-être autre chose à faire qu'à
part les quatre ans avant tout le monde
y compris la profession tout le monde ne
parle que de ça et après tout comme
j'aime le dire prenons entre guillemets
et mon au sérieux ces dangereuses que
disait moi je vous le dis je trouve
dangereux quenum credit event et 11% à
les basques à 11%
teasé nord a demandé ces noms aux
français de choisir entre l'islam et la
france ça veut dire que dans ce pays il
ya cinq à six millions de concitoyens
moi je suis pas croyant et je suis pas
musulman mais il ya cinq assémian nous
constituons qui croit cette religion
comme ya aujourd'hui plusieurs centaines
de milliers de juifs comme il ya des
catholiques mais déjà des gens
n'ont ni compris parce que vous incarnez
cyrine sur ce plateau le fait que depuis
tous les gens que vous invitez justement
vous êtes à l'image de cette france on
quelles que soient les convictions
spirituelles car on arrive à discuter et
y en a un qui dit qu' on va demander aux
gens de choisir entre leur religion et
ce pays ça c'est un discours de guerre
civile de guerre civile et c'est pour ça
que ces mots ayant côté supercherie et
baudruche c'est que si on les coudes ce
qu'il appelle la remise gracieuse terre
dire à des gens qui sont ici dont les
parents sont nés ici qui vont retourner
au bled c'est l'armée française qui va
faire ça si cet homme prend des
responsabilités clairement ce pays
explosent et je vais vous dire c'est le
pendant des djihadistes ya les
djihadistes qui veulent casser le pays
en disant être musulman c'est assassiné
ayant fou comme seymour qui dit on va
virer tous les musulmans moi je leur
tire entre les deux pays et ce discours
de haine pour le combat revanche à l'en
croire
ce que tu me dis oh face moi je trouve
ça génial mais pour le moment un autre
pas ses mots il est pas comme il n'est
pas candidat encore oui c'est à c'est un
essayiste à pau les mises d'accord c'est
quelqu'un qui a écrit et c'est un peu la
verve du général de gaulle c'est un peu
pompidou ccc 5000 ex mais bien sûr il
fait d y va il voit un peu le chat noir
mais attendez d'accord car jean chalon
c'est bien tout le monde sait qu'il a
une équipe de campagne il est en train
de réunir des fonds il ya des gens qui
collent des affiches pour lui ils
s'organisent d'accord
mais comme arnaud montebourg les a pas
comme anne hidalgo chez même pas si elle
sera candidate comme plein de gens qui
disent qu'ils sont comme
les gens du btp alors je vais vous dire
je vais vous dire les choses celle là je
triais même sa [ __ ] gauche aurait les
moyens d'être candidate mais je ne sais
pas si elle arrivait alors a vraiment
envie d'y aller à l'heure actuelle on
est dans un moment où plein de gens
disent je suis candidat zemmour lui fait
inverse il fait tout comme le candidat
mehdi je suis pas candidat pour pouvoir
biaisé vis-à-vis des mets du temps de
parole et crs c'est un malin tu as une
stratégie oui mais politiquement il
parle politiquement écouter ce que
disent les peurs et règlements mais bien
mais moi ça me fait peur qu'un projet il
faut faire il vous fait peur il vous
fait peur s'il arrive six présente et
qu'il arrive devant jean-luc mélenchon
ce serait là et reebok eric des
illusions non mais surtout ce qui me
fait peur c'est que dans ce pays aussi à
des millions de gens qui se
reconnaissent dans quelqu'un qui dit en
gros ce que je viens d'écrire tout à
l'heure un programme de guerre civile
qu'on va s'affronter oui ça me fait peur
parce que je vais vous dire ce pays il a
aujourd'hui il est mal jan 11 millions
de gens qu'il seuil de pauvreté il ya
une crise écologique sans précédent 70%
des gens vont plus voter si ce qui monte
et le danger est là ce sont des idées
que le problème c'est pas qu'on partage
des richesses le problème c'est la faute
aux immigrés et en particulier aux
musulmans on va s'affronter en plus vous
avez des flux qui au nom de l'islam font
des attentats
donc si on accepte ça et qu'on n'est pas
sur un discours de revenons et c'est
compliqué de le dire à la grande
promesse républicaine bien sûr alexis
braud non mais je sens belle existence
et sa salle dussault politiciens sur
jean-luc j'espère qu'il réussira
peut-être qu'il va vous pensez qu'il va
être meilleur que eric zemmour dans le
démarrage mais je
l'espère mais je pense que les deux sont
des gens expérimentés on va avoir de
cohérence fait ça et j'aimerais que ce
soit il un prêtre en compte et que les
gens comprennent et là j'espère que cela
arrivera faire jean luc est lancé dès
mon crime un don à merci si son départ
il regardait les gens disent non à 52%
oui à 47% tout